If rainbows are during the day and moonbows
are at night, why don't they call daybows...
something else?
Hey everyone, Trace here for a DNews.
Aren’t rainbows just beautiful?
We typically think of them as daytime occurrences,
but believe it or not, moonbows, also known
as lunar rainbows, appear at night!
Before we get into the nitty gritty on moonbows,
though, we should probably explain regular
daytime rainbows...
Rainbows appear when sunlight passes through
water droplets in the air.
The sun produces white light, which, as you
know, is actually a combination of all the
possible colors.
The water droplets act like glass prisms,
bending the light as it passes through them
separating white into its component parts,
creating a rainbow!
ROYGBIV!
Red, orange, yellow, green, blue, indigo,
and violet.
The water in the air can be from recent rainfall,
or say, mist from nearby waterfalls.
But to make a rainbow the sunlight needs to
hit the raindrops at about a 42 degree angle
for red light, and 40 for violet.
And double rainbows are simply reflecting
the light through the raindrops more than
once!
This might blow your mind a little, but rainbows
don’t actually exist up in the air.
Their presence and appearance in the sky are
dependant on your exact location.
The water droplets in the air above you are
different than the ones above, say, your friend
who lives on the other side of town and will
refract the light differently.
Remember the double rainbow guy?
Of, course you do.
He saw those majestic bows all the way across
the sky, but they actually go even further,
because the light doesn't just reflect out
of the raindrops in an arc, but in all directions.
This is why sometimes people in airplanes
can see rainbows as full circles!
So, what about moonbows?
They're very similar…
Instead of direct sunlight reflecting through
raindrops, the water droplets in the air refract
moonlight… which, by the way, is technically
still sunlight, since the moon just reflects
distant sunlight and doesn’t emit any light
of its own.
The best time to see a moonbow is around the
time of a full moon because the moon is brighter
and is giving off more light to refract.
Besides the obvious time of day difference,
moonbows do look a bit different as well.
While daytime rainbows are full of color,
the moon isn’t as bright as the sun so there’s
less light being refracted through the water
droplets.
This means that moonbows are most often seen
as plain white arcs in the sky.
But thankfully, long exposure photographs
bring out their colors and we can appreciate
these rare beauties in all their glory.
So rainbows and moonbows are pretty cool,
but the one thing that doesn’t exist at
all is that pot
of gold at the end.
If you are looking for gold, remember to visit
Kay Jewelers.
Special thanks to Kay Jewelers for sponsoring
this episode.
For 100 Years, Every kiss begins with Kay.
Rainbows have all the colors of white light,
red, orange, yellow, green, blue, indigo and
violet, but what if you could see more colors
than the average person?
Check out this video about people who can
see 100 million colors.
Maybe you’re one of them.
Have you ever seen a moonbow?
Or a triple rainbow?
Yes, that can happen too.
Let us know in the comments and keep coming
back here everyday for more DNews.